let's do a problem similar to what we
just finished doing in the previous
video but instead of
adding or saying you know what is a
hundred more than a given number or a
thousand more let's see what happens
when we take away what happens when we
take
a number that's a thousand less or a
hundred less than a given number so
let's pick our number to be
five thousand seven which i'm using the
right tool
five thousand
seven hundred
and thirty two
so first of all let's write down 5732 in
terms of our
in terms of our
poker chips or in terms of our cans of
marbles so 5 000 so let's see if i can
draw 5 000.
it's green so it's one
two
three
four
five
right and each of those are a thousand
each of those are a thousand
at 700 that's going to take me a little
time to draw
700
1 2
3
4. five
six
seven hundred those last to overlap
100
100
100
100
100 hundred hundred
i have three tens
it's one
two
three tens
ten
10 10 and i have two ones that's easy
two ones
so one
two
two ones
so let's say what happens when i what if
i were to ask you what is
i don't know
1000
less
than 5732
well this is
5700 thirty two so if i take if i say
what is one thousand less what am i
doing well i'm essentially going to take
away a bucket of a thousand or a can of
a thousand marbles or i'm going to take
away
a a 1 000 poker chip so let's look at
our thousands well we have one two three
four five thousands i'm going to take
one of them away
so let me take and let me take this one
let me
i'll just cross it out so i'm going to
essentially what's one thousand less let
me take away one of these so i'm going
to take this one away
so what's the resulting number
how many thousands do i have left if i
took this one away i have one two three
four
four thousand how many hundreds well i
still have seven hundreds right one two
three four five six seven didn't change
that
three tens
thirty
two ones
two
four thousand seven hundred thirty two
and if we if we didn't do it using our
poker chips or using our uh cans of
marbles you could just say well if you
took a thousand away from five thousand
seven hundred and thirty two
you essentially just take up you take
one from the thousands place this
equivalent of taking away one thousand
so we took away one from the five and we
got four here so four thousand seven
hundred and thirty two
fair enough
let me erase this
and i did not want to erase with the
yellow
i'll have to draw that
that
thousand chip back
erase it first
let me draw that back
so
the original number is 5000 so that's
why i wanted that to be back there
so what happens if instead of saying
what is a thousand less than 5732
what happens if i ask you
what is
i don't know what is one less
what is one less than 5732
well just like when we did a thousand
less we took away a thousand dollar
poker chip if we want one less we'll
take away a one dollar poker chip so
essentially we could take away
one chip
right i took that away so what do we
have left we have
five thousand
and i'll just do it in one color well i
know i'm gonna actually do it this way
we have
five thousand
seven hundred still seven hundred
thirty three tens is thirty and we took
one away here so we only have one left
i'm just counting them so we have five
thousand seven hundred and thirty one
which makes sense you take away one from
five thousand seven hundred thirty two
you're taking one away from the ones
place so the two
goes down by one to become a one right
here
so let me add back that
that one dollar that i took out
to do another problem
so what happens if i were let me erase
some of this
so what happens if i were to ask you
what is
what is
100
less than 5732
well i'm gonna take away a hundred chip
right
so let me just i'll just erase it i've
always been erasing the bottom one but i
could erase any of them so i'm going to
take one of these 700s away
i erased that one it disappeared doesn't
exist anymore so now what do i have left
i have 5 000
5000 how many hundreds you have one two
three four five six six hundred that
makes sense i had seven i took away i
have six now i had seven i took one of
the hundreds away i have six now
three tens
thirty
two ones
let's do one left one more well before i
do that i have to add that hundred back
that i just took away
add the hundred there we go
let me erase this
erase that
let's say what is 10 less
what is 10 less than 5732
well that means we take away a 10 chip
away from from our collection of chips
so what is 10 less let me just erase one
of the tens that's gone
so now we have
five thousand
seven hundred
we have two tens two tens
and two ones
so 5722
is what we get when we take 10 away from
5732
which makes sense because we took 10
away so we decreased the tens place by
one to get 5722
so let's do a couple of exercises now
that i think you have a familiar
familiarity with what happens when we
add 10 to a number or take away 10 from
a number or add 100 or a thousand or one
let's see if we can count by a hundred
or a thousand or by one or
different orders
so what i want you to do is count in
steps of 10. so count
in steps
of 10
from
1678
to one thousand seven hundred and twenty
eight
let's see if we can do that so the first
it's one thousand
six hundred and seventy eight so we're
counting the steps of ten so we're
adding a ten every time so when you add
ten you add you increase the tens place
by one so
1678 when you add 10 becomes 1688
right we just added 10. let's add 10
more we get 1 698
and now once again if we add if we just
incremented this digit by one we get a
10 here but you can't have 10
you can't have 10 tens but you wouldn't
write it that way what happens when you
have 10 tens
that means you have an extra hundred
right ten tens equal a hundred so now
instead of incrementing this and getting
a ten somehow in the tens place we say
oh well we're gonna have ten tens so
let's increment the hundreds place
so we get one thousand
seven hundred and we used all of these
plus one more to get that extra hundred
so now we have
zero
tens
eight so it's one thousand seven hundred
and eight
and now from here it's actually pretty
straightforward we keep incrementing the
tens place again
1718
1728
1000 oh that's where we wanted to go
we're done
let's do another one
i'll switch colors let's let's step in a
hundred counts
count in steps of a hundred
from
1678
to
2178
let's see what we can do
so we have
one thousand six hundred and seventy
eight
we we're incrementing by a hundred so we
add one to the hundredths digit every
time so we now we have one thousand
seven hundred and seventy eight
one thousand eight hundred and seventy
eight
one thousand nine hundred and seventy
eight
and now something interesting happens
we are going to add another hundred so
we would have ten hundred
but ten hundred once again you can't
have a ten in the hundreds place you
can't put a two digit number there
and ten hundreds also equal a thousand
so this is going to actually this
instead of having nine hundred we say
well we have one more thousand so we
take those nine and we're adding another
hundred we get another thousand so we
increment the thousands place we get
two thousand now
and so and and we use all of these up
plus the extra hundred to get that extra
thousand so now we we're going back to
zero hundreds
seventy-eight
and then we keep adding hundreds again
two thousand
one hundred and seventy-eight
let's do one more
i want to count in steps
of a thousand
from six 1678
to 8
678. this is pretty straightforward so
we start 1678
what's a thousand plus that
well when you add a thousand you're
essentially adding one to the thousands
place so you get 2
678
3678
4678
5678 i think you get the point 6
seventy eight
seven thousand seven hundred seventy
eight and then we get eight thousand
seven hundred
sorry
actually i messed up
even the best of us can make careless
mistakes i actually incremented the
hundreds place here
six thousand six hundred seventy eight
we're only increasing by the thousands
place we get seven thousand six hundred
and seventy eight and then we get
eight thousand six hundred and seventy
eight you can't do anything too quickly
all right now this unit we just have one
more set of exercises i think it's good
you know so i'm i just want to do all of
them
so i'm going to give you a set of
numbers and i want you to complete the
blank so let's say we went from three
thousand
ninety eight
to three thousand
nine nine
and i have a blank here
then i got three thousand
hundred and one
and then three thousand hundred and two
put commas here so you know these are
different numbers
so what do we do we go from three
thousand ninety eight to three thousand
ninety nine what did we do we increased
by one right
and we're going from three thousand one
to one to 3102 we also increased by one
so essentially this looks like we're
just increasing by one every time so
what's one more than 3099
let's remember
we have
when you add 1 to 99
you're essentially getting a hundred
right you could say three thousand
one hundred
and it makes sense then that when you
add one to that you get 101 102. this
was the hard one to figure out right
because when you increment the ones
place by one you get a 10 there and you
say oh no now i have 10 ones so i have
an extra 10. and so you you want to so
you instead of writing this 3910 you
can't write that so you exchange those
tens those 10 ones for an extra 10 so
then you might say 3010
0
but you can't have that either so
exchange those 10
tens for 100 and you get 3
100 and nothing else that's what we got
there
let's do that a couple of more times so
let's say we have
i don't know
3098
3108
three thousand
one hundred eighteen
let's say blank
and then three thousand one hundred
thirty eight
put some commas in so what happened when
we went from three thousand ninety eight
to three thousand one hundred and eight
what did we do
what's the difference between three
thousand ninety eight and three thousand
one hundred and eight
the ones place is the same but if we
look at the tens place
we what happens when you increment this
by one when you increase the tenths
place by one you can't put a ten there
right
so when you have you have nine tens here
this is a tens place you equivalent
number one you have ten tens what was
ten tens it's a hundred
so you could you exchange all of those
add the extra one and you get an extra
one there so all we did here is we
increased by ten
and you see that here again one thousand
one hundred eight one thousand one
hundred eighteen we increased by ten
because the tens place increased by one
so let's increase by ten again we just
increment the tenths place three
thousand one hundred
and twenty eight
let's do one more of these
and there are a couple more in the
workbook but i think you you get the
idea
start with the same number 3009
3098
a blank
and i really encourage you to pause
these before i tell you how to do them
see if you can do it themselves
5098
6098
seven thousand
ninety-eight
well this might be obvious i mean you
don't know what the next one is because
you just have one number so you know
what the pattern is but you go five
thousand six five thousand ninety eight
six thousand ninety eight seven thousand
ninety eight so it sounds like
after everyone we're just increasing the
thousands by one right we're adding a
thousand
so this is three thousand ninety eight
let's add a thousand four thousand
ninety eight
five thousand ninety eight that's it
let's do
actually we've been doing uh actually i
think i want to do one or two more just
to make sure we we get all the concepts
in
so let's say i have
and
8903
and then i have
a blank number
here
and then i have
eight thousand eight hundred
eighty-three
eight thousand eight hundred seventy
three
and then eight thousand eight hundred
sixty three
so there's a couple of ways we see it's
hard to figure out a pattern we only
have one number here but we could look
at these what happens we bring eight
thousand eight hundred eighty three
eight thousand eight hundred seventy
three so we decreased the tens place by
one
then we have eight thousand eight
hundred sixty three we decrease the tens
place by one so we're decreasing by ten
every time
minus 10.
so this number right here must be 10
more than this number
so what's 10 more than this number
well we increase the tens place by one
and we get 8893
this is interesting because when we
subtract 10 from here how do we do that
how do we subtract 10 from here from 8
900
and 3
well we have nothing in the tens place
right there so we do is we take one of
these hundreds so we only have 800 left
we take one of them we exchange them for
10 tens and then we take one of those
tens away so we say this is the same
thing as eight thousand eight hundred
and then ten tens
and a three
right if we think of the places as a
tenth place and now we decrease it by
one and we get this
eight thousand eight hundred and ninety
three
i think that gives you good intuition
and this this videos run very long so i
will see you actually in the next unit
see you soon